hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
andrew andrew first time here he's
actually a huge movie buff doesn't do
anything with the film industry but i
talked with this guy at a party and he
knows more than I do it's [ __ ] insane
and just how much this guy knows so I
thought we'd sit down together from
all-time movies channel we're gonna
check out their video 5 biggest
blockbuster flops I have a feeling I
know which ones these are gonna be yeah
I'm kind of curious to see what it is
but I think I was feeling - I feel like
stealth will be in there I feel like
what's Adventures of Pluto Nash yeah I
could see that in there - what was that
Will Ferrell movie with the dinosaurs oh
yeah I was already silvering the
director of Casper movies terrible but I
mean he knows [ __ ] like terrible hi I'm
Jamie for all-time movies and these are
the five biggest flops ever you know
right now money in movies is a tricky
business Studios spend hundreds of
millions of dollars making a movie but
then they split the money 5050 with the
cinemas so each big blockbuster needs to
gross at least twice its budget before
it starts turning a profit and sometimes
it just goes terribly terribly wrong
yep let's look at the five biggest
Hollywood box-office flops ever teeth
were number five yes
where the hell is that stealth flocked
because it's rubbish it's not even so
bad it's good although the plot about an
artificially intelligent stealth plane
going haywire is so daft it's almost
memorable Jamie Foxx make this right
after winning his Oscar for a and it
killed Josh Lucas's blockbuster career
before it even started ah and totally
knows how Jessica Biel kept getting work
[Music]
did you them yeah number four
forty-seven Ronin oh man the famous
story of forty-seven Japanese samurai
who avenged their murdered master
actually happened in the 18th century
so naturally Hollywood turned in in some
weird medieval full of CGI monsters
demons and Keanu Reeves
because Eastern cultures always need a
white man to save the day
Wow as you might expect this one didn't
strike a chord with audiences and the
film made a big loss the odd thing is
it's actually quite fun that's good to
hear
number three John Carter I am poor John
Carter his name is so deliberately
generic that it's almost impossible to
sell a non fashion sci-fi movie named
after him unsurprisingly the movie of
the story that inspired every sci-fi
fantasy ever was badly marketed and lost
his knee over 100 million dollars which
is a shame because the film's got loads
more depth wit and brilliant visuals
than all of the Star Wars prequels
especially episode 2 number 2 the 13th
warrior I actually like this movie
[Music]
back in the 90s Michael Crichton was all
the rage and Antonio Banderas could
carry a blockbuster team him up with the
director of die hard and you're on to a
winner right here
Crichton dislike the director's cut so
he reshot most of the film himself and
trimmed it from over two hours loud just
90 minutes and no idea as a result the
budget spiraled to a massive 160 million
dollars and you can't really see the
difference this also meant that it lost
even more money than director's cut
would have done number one
Mars Needs Moms sorry mums remember
Easter Lots so badly that Disney
insisted John Carter removed the of Mars
epithet from its name now we all know
that didn't help it's just lame the
motion capture animations charmless the
script isn't funny and the aliens are
gangster
me not before not busting you so there
you have it the five biggest flops in
Hollywood history did any of them
surprise you why do you think these
films flopped let me know in the
comments below thanks for watching and
please subscribe if you like this video
and would like to see more check out the
five biggest Star Wars plot holes wow
dude um 13th warrior actually shocks me
I know it wasn't successful I had no
idea the budget was that ridiculously
high and that it lost so much [ __ ]
money as I liked that movie yeah I
actually liked that movie too and that's
John McTiernan that's the director of
the first die hard yeah man the third
die hard film and he and Predator one of
my all-time favorite films though I mean
he's a great filmmaker so if you would
have told me that's gonna be in the top
five that big of a loss I never would
have believed that so that's very
interesting to see and reading I had no
idea that Michael Crichton that did a
whole reshoe reshoot on it like that I'd
never heard that so and then authors had
power like that today Wow
whoa 50 shades of grey would have been
totally different right no they
authorized just don't have that kind of
strength anymore that is [ __ ] insane
and then I mean stealth was the only one
I got right yeah it was a good call I
mean that's Rob Cohen who did that he
directed the first furious and he did
drag in the Bruce Lee story but I mean
yeah from the trailers of that movie I
that from when I remember when I saw
that was like that does not look very
good I mean still give it a chance but
it was not very good so that's not a
shocker at all just a boring plot idea
it's we also watch a plot of is that
ridiculous I mean it's like Skynet by
itself in a jet or something oh yeah
cool 47 Ronin with Keanu Reeves yeah I
mean I'm telling if you would have just
said like you know oh I am an FBI agent
I thought that would have made it more
interesting that's me personally but
yeah that movie this visually was
interesting but it's one of those bad
movies that's kind of fun though you
know I know it's it's one of the things
that you could take from it is like it's
the least fun and dumb and yeah yeah I
know if you turn your brain off it's a
guilty pleasure you can have
with it no doubt but I had no idea made
that big of a loss so that's interesting
to see it wasn't advertised like that it
was advertised as like this epic action
masterpiece yeah yeah absolutely and
mood and yeah casting Keanu Reeves in it
I thought was a big mistake you know
yeah because like yeah okay you did the
matrix this is about Japanese people but
I'm like we don't need Jana Reeves
I completely agree I actually didn't
catch John Carter cause of how dad I
heard it was but they did say it was
smarter than the Star Wars prequels
which I found myself going you know I
could see that yeah I agree to that but
that's not saying a lot you know I mean
because in the when you come to the Star
Wars prequels I know we're getting a
little off topic here you know that's
more George Lucas having a bunch of yes
people around him and doing whatever the
heck he wants I'll agree - I mean this
was a little you know smarter than Star
Wars prequels but that's not saying a
lot so but it was sucks cause it was the
director of wall-e
you know and yes doing it's like live
feature film and it sucks because you
know like when Brad Bird came from Pixar
when it's a feature film so tomorrow I
didn't do well the grouse protocols are
possible so good that's I love that
movie that's the best one out of the
Mission Possible fetch our I can't wait
to see the fifth one even though he's
not involved with that I think it's
Christopher McQuarrie the Jack Reacher
direct yeah yeah I'm still curious to
see that but yeah Brad Bird made such a
great jump from animated to live so I
was curious to see I think this is
Andrew Stanton well I think you're right
so I think yeah I mean I was very
curious to see you know him jump from
you know Disney or animated to live you
know who's okay not that great but I had
no idea was this big of a flop I knew it
was a flop and not to this extent so oh
yeah I heard it was a huge flop and he
used to be called like John Carter was a
man from Mars something like that yeah
the war yeah they were playing her right
they kept on changing and it was kept
thinking something like that yeah
something like that
well the problem with John Carr I mean
you don't name this epic sci-fi 250
million dollar budget film such a
typical name John Carter so if you
actually add the man from Mars it makes
it sound a little different and they
should have kept this subtitle I
completely agree that makes it sound
much more interesting than John Carter
yeah sounds so generic and they said
they did that because of the first movie
that flaw
mom from Mars or something like that I
forgot let's go I remember seeing a
trailer for that now and remember going
this looks horrible sure enough it was I
didn't know what the biggest flop of all
time though yeah that's pretty [ __ ]
insane I yeah I had not was creative
would what did they say that movie lost
130 130 million almost 131 million wow
that is [ __ ] nuts that's crazy I mean
I never personally saw that film but wow
that's a lot you know watching this
video just terrifies me because making
movies like producing them must be so
[ __ ] scary oh absolutely because they
bring up a great point that they set to
split the money so they have to at least
double that like you you think like
people are walking away with way more
money than they're actually getting a
lot of it time you know like that's
[ __ ] insane to lose damage I mean
also think about how much marketing
costs - just alone yeah you got to get
your money back and double it triple it
or you're not gonna make anything back
and then when you get guys like you know
again getting a little off-topic you get
guys like Robert Downey jr. getting
amazing deals and stuff like in Avengers
where he gets a humongous chunk of the
percentage now you know how much profit
are they really making you know what I
mean so obviously different films were
there making it Tiger roast but it's
just it shows you like a lot of power
some of these actors have and some of
these producers I completely agree it
would be terrifying to have to be a
producer
absolutely you got to know exactly what
this movie like sometimes you take too
big a gamble
they shouldn't have called the John
Carter absolutely should have called the
John Carter yeah man from Mars sounds
much more interesting than John Carter
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow answer on Twitter at something
balls was at a Gore 7-eleven a your
7-eleven sorry
so that's not that's not pretty good too
but balls 7-eleven egg or 7-eleven egg
or 7-eleven follow him on Twitter there
and you can follow the real rejects on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope I don't know if you have any
of those I don't
ok maybe someday soon because if we get
more followers we can get even more
product placement people that's right
making money on YouTube a lot of
youtubers don't admit to that they want
to kind of keep it in the shadows but
you know what I have millions of dollars
millions because I watch other people's
content and talk about it see Andrew
it's about getting respect respect